your mother
was Leon the stock and you Father
your real father was Rhaegar Targaryen
you've never been the bastard you're
aegon targaryen true heir to the Iron
Throne
yeah it's not fun thing to tell no I can
I come from Manchester and there doesn't
tell anybody that but but I think the
thing about that is that if if Johnny's
gonna find out that quite key piece of
information he'd rather hear it from
someone anybody else because he knows
that Sam is the person who it will be
doing it for the right reasons and he's
not got an agenda he's not trying to
cause trouble he's just telling him
because he feels he needs to know so as
far as John goes if he has to hear that
you've been doing that if you have to
hear that you've been doing that you'd
rather of you're loyal and honest best
friend tell you then you're the true
king aegon targaryen vi of his name
protector of the realm all of it right
now because she put Jon Snow and
Denarius together quite the matchmaker
and I've got a goodwill you think the
Lord of Light necessarily cares that
Dany is technically Jon's aunt I think
the Lord of Light is a bit like it would
be pretty progressive yeah this is one
of the reason I don't follow him the
whole interesting answer Davos has
become one of John's most trusted
advisors how awkward is that when that
revelation comes to pass we turn that
attack there's a lot of them when he
walks into the room yeah I don't I don't
really want to bring it up really with
him and it's kind of you know I mean of
all the incest in Game of Thrones oh
that's not so bad is it as a couple of
degrees yeah brother and sister Nicci